also welcome the permanent secretary and
we're very pleased to see Dan o'mahoni
again we
sorry Mahoney Marney oh sorry sorry
Marley sorry
um we saw you very recently and uh you
obviously have the role of the
clandestine Channel threat Commander so
we're very pleased that you're with us
today
um just want to make a few brief remarks
it's nine months since we were able to
question a Home Secretary and obviously
a lot has happened since February of
this year
with the Rwanda announcement
um the crisis at manston and our report
in the summer on the Small Boat
Crossings so we've got many questions
that we want to ask today and we will
start with
um the issue around Asylum Seekers the
channel Boat Crossings and manston but I
think it's also right that we remember
today that we are coming up to the
one-year anniversary of those 27 who
lost their lives crossing the channel
and also that we recognize in the last
few days the sad news of the death of a
man who had been detained at manston
we also note the welcome news that
manston was cleared just before the home
secretary's appearance at this select
committee and it does beg the question
why the crisis at manston was allowed to
grow over at such an extended period if
it has been cleared now
and just finally I just want to say I am
particularly disappointed
that a letter dated the 2nd of November
from the chairs of four select
committees
uh justice The Joint Committee on human
rights and women inequalities plus
myself has not been responded to by the
home office we asked for a response by
the 16th of November and that letter
arose out the very disturbing evidence
that we heard at our session on manston
so that is very disappointing that we
haven't had the answer to the specific
questions that we raised in that letter
and that then leads me on to my specific
questions
and these are mainly factual questions
that I just want to get some clarity on
so first of all can I just ask how many
judicial reviews have been launched
against the home office for illegal
detention at manston as of today
who can tell me that well if I if I'm as
uh may I Madam chair thank you very much
for the invitation to come and speak to
the committee I really value the
opportunity for accountability and
transparency
um you note the um I should say at the
outset that um uh I I also want to offer
my condolences and my thoughts
um in the memory of those 27 uh who
perished almost a life a year ago on the
channel
taking a lethal dangerous journey and it
is a tragedy on a scale that is
unacceptable and I'm very very sorry uh
that and saddened
um that that happened and any any loss
of life in this instance is a is of
great sadness I also want to put on
record my heartfelt condolences to all
those affected by the death of the
person who arrived recently at manston
um there's very little I can say about
that because there is a a an inquest in
a Coroner's inquiry going on to that but
I do want to put on record on behalf of
the home office and everyone who works
on the front line uh in these very
challenging circumstances our thoughts
for for those who are directly affected
you also mentioned the letter of the
16th of November uh I must say I'm I
apologize for not getting a reply back
to you second of November sorry 2nd of
November with the deadline of the 16th
of November uh I'm not I'm that there
has been a processing issue in the in
the home office and we will endeavor to
to respond very quickly but I am happy
to take any of the questions that are
raised in that letter today
um the question that you asked me about
now is how many judicial reviews we are
actually facing I mean
I speak to someone who was a lawyer
employed to defend the home office
before I was an MP on judicial reviews
so the number the number is will be very
high I mean in terms of uh the total
number of judicial reviews of the home
office is dealing with this issue on the
issue of manston and illegal detention
I don't have the number uh chair but we
will write to you with it told it's four
you don't know
you don't know how many judicial reviews
on manston have been launched we know
that there are judicial reviews on
manston and we are we are dealing with
them as you as you would expect in a in
a in a holistic way I uh personally
didn't know that there were four but we
will we will um uh okay I'm rather
surprised if you don't mind me saying
I'm rather surprised you you didn't
think I might ask that question but
anyway okay I just want to be clear now
then on the legal status of manston so
could you just confirm I don't know if
this is the permanent secretary who can
confirm this is manston a holding room
and therefore detention is only allowed
up to 24 hours
is that correct well um the manston
processing center is there as a uh
fundamentally a center for a short-term
facility for processing uh people arrive
and I'll ask we know what happens there
I just want to know what the legal
status is is it a holding room
in law
it's a short-term holding facility is it
a holding room as as set out in the
India it's equivalent to a a holding
room which means that we can
um under the rules keep people there for
24 hours apart from in exceptional
circumstances okay so that's helpful so
it's a holding room and you then in the
exceptional circumstances you can then
hold people for a further period of
detention
under the rules it's very clear that if
you want to use that provision and
extend detention there has to be an
authorization made before the 24 hours
runs out so perhaps your best place to
tell me
did that happen for everybody who was
held at manston Beyond 24 hours yeah
there's a process of a director level
signing off the exceptional
circumstances that we can hold people
Beyond 24 hours but probably also worth
saying there is another legal obligation
upon the department which is to provide
accommodation to stop people from being
destitute so I mean clearly there were
people staying amongst them in excess of
24 hours but it's also really really
important that we find alternative
accommodation when when when the
alternative is destitution was that the
exceptional circumstance that was put on
for each individual that you were
extending the period of detention for
that goes where the exceptional
circumstances that led to us keeping
people there for more than 24 hours okay
I think we'll come on to this but why
was that an exceptional circumstance
because we all know that the numbers
projected for this year were going to
exceed the 28 and a half thousand from
last year coming across this on the
small boat so sorry I'm not quite clear
why this was exceptional why did the
home office not have plans in place to
deal with the numbers
so
um
as we discussed on your visit the
primary currently the primary
accommodation that we offer to Asylum
Seekers is hotels and the provision of
hotels the commercial protests that we
had to go through the engagement with
local MPS and local authorities became
very very difficult
um increasingly become very difficult
sorry why did it become very difficult I
mean there are a range of reasons um one
is you know market supply has become
much more difficult you know compared to
last year when you know hotels didn't
have people staying in them uh in the
way that they do now
um you've been able to clear it I mean
you we started off by saying that you'd
cleared manston so I'm a bit confused as
to why you're saying hotels were not
available because you've clearly found
hotels to put people in now yeah I mean
the other factor that has um worked in
our favor over the last few weeks is
that the weather has deteriorated
significantly so the number of Crossings
has dropped so the number of the number
of Crossings this November is
significantly lower than it was last
November for instance the crisis was
developing wasn't it and I'm looking at
the numbers
um in in August you had nearly eight and
a half thousand and then in September 7
900 October 6900 so you knew these
numbers were coming because you weren't
working on the basis of 60 000 people
crossing the channel weren't you
and we we certainly anticipated that the
numbers would be worse than last year
yes
what happened is we have during during
the month of September
um it was obvious that there were
already an unprecedented or at least
very very high number of people who were
arriving illegally at Dover uh we were
uh trying to procure uh uh extra
accommodation
urgently and at PACE it is it has become
incredibly difficult to find
accommodation and that is because of a
combination of several factors we've got
an unprecedented number of people
arriving here illegally well I don't
think that's the case I could just
interrupt you there because actually the
numbers are not unprecedented if you
look back to 2002 the number of people
claiming Asylum was almost twice the
claims that you had last year so I don't
think that's actually correct and that's
in our report that we produced in the
summer I'm sorry uh Madam chair
um the facts are this is the first time
we have had before the end of the year
by the Autumn 40 000 people arrive
illegally at the UK through a dangerous
route where they are vulnerable
can I just finish explaining some of the
context that I've been dealing
absolutely but the key is we haven't got
that much time yeah there's lots of
questions we want to ask I've got lots
of members who want to to come in on
this perhaps I could just move you on to
what you actually decided to do as Home
Secretary because there's been lots of
media coverage of what happened during
September and October and I just want to
ask you when did you first become aware
that there was this crisis developing at
manston and when were you told that you
were potentially in breach of the law by
holding people well I arrived at the
home office at the beginning of the
September in full awareness that there
was a crisis
uh with illegal migration because of the
very high and I just have to finish the
point that I was making there is an
unprecedented level of pressure on our
Asylum accommodation system at the
moment we we've never seen 40 000 people
arrive in the UK through dangerous and
illegal means we've never had uh a
hundred and forty thousand people
welcomed in good faith and rightly so
from Ukraine who are to some degree
taking up uh some of our accommodation
we've never seen in addition to that
another 80 000 people who we are
accommodating who are waiting for their
Asylum claims that all takes up beds and
accommodation and a state it is becoming
incredibly difficult to Source
accommodations suitable
shelter for the unprecedented levels of
people coming into this country we are
competing with prisons who want to
release to go into accommodation we are
competing with constituents
when you came in as Home Secretary
you're saying you knew there was a
crisis so when were you told of the
developing problem at manston that
people could only be held for 24 hours
there was exceptional circumstances to
extend that we understand technically a
maximum of five days so when were you
told that the home office was breaching
the law
as I've said
when I first arrived at the home office
at the beginning of September I was
incredibly aware of the pressure once
you told you were breaching the law and
I was uh putting into place and I will
invite the permanent secretary confirm
exactly what happened my question's
quite specific when were you told that
the home office was breaching the law
around detaining people for more to get
to that point but I need to tell you
what I did in September and what I knew
that's what I'm trying to do that we
just need the date when were you told
you started as Home Secretary how many
days later were you told about the
problem
was it day one I would really like to
finish my answer tell us what I'm trying
to tell you what I knew and what I did
okay well please tell us I was appointed
as Home Secretary okay right so when I
arrived at in at the beginning of
September at the home office I was very
much aware that there were very high
levels of people numbers coming in to
Dover I was very aware yeah that there
were as a an acute need to Source
accommodation
urgently and quickly and that's why
during the month of September we brought
on many hotels and many beds with the
greatest respect my specific question to
you is when did your officials tell you
that there was the developing problem at
manston and that you were breaching the
law right well I'm I'm I will answer
that in a straightforward and I'll have
to repeat myself I was aware from the
beginning of my tenure that there was a
problem at manston when it comes to
legal advice which you're asking
specifically about it is a government
convention that we don't talk about out
the issuance or the content of legal
advice but what I will say is that in
every decision that I've made both as
Home Secretary and as generally a
minister and I say this as a former
Attorney General I have always you know
whenever I've been provided with legal
advice by officials I've always taken it
into account Reddit listen to it when
it's been delivered to me orally and and
born it in mind when decisions have to
be made if you're suggesting that I
either wasn't told about legal advice
ignored it that is simply not sure
I cannot for convention reasons and also
because we are facing legal challenge
get into the specifics about what legal
advice and when was given right so and
can I just invite the permanent
secretary to add anything that he might
want to add about what happened I I can
confirm chair that that what Home
Secretary said is is accurate that the
home office uh officials made the Home
Secretary aware of the legal position as
well as policy options from the
beginning of her tenure right thank you
I want to support to you this then it's
reported that on the 15th of September
you were informed about the the
deepening problem at manston and that
you are likely to be in breach of the
law that was the 15th of September so
you'd been in post I think nine days
when you were given a submission to say
there was a problem then I understand
you were given a second submission on
the 22nd of September saying there was a
very high risk that you were in breach
of the law 50 to 70 percent then on the
1st of October you were again told there
was a very high risk that you're in
breach of the law and then on the 4th of
October again 50 to 70 percent you were
in breach of the law and the advice was
that the home office does not have power
to detain while waiting for onward
accommodation or welfare reasons so are
those correct those that's been in the
Press leaked documents from the home
office well I'm afraid I'm not going to
comment on leagues and I'm not going to
comment on the specifics of legal advice
whether the fact the fact or the content
of it that's not how government work for
the judicial review that that have been
launched already I'm assuming these
papers will all have to be made
available for the judicial review so we
will know whether what I've just read
out to you is correct
we will fulfill our Duty account and we
will make sure that the the uh that the
courts uh receive the relevant papers
okay can I just ask a question in the
letter you wrote To Me Home Secretary
about your reason uh that you resigned
um in October Madam chair can I just
finish off one point because I think
it's important that I need to explain
because I haven't already had a chance
to fully explain in response to that
kind of very briefly very fairly so of
course I'm very aware of legal duties to
accommodate incoming migrants their
welfare their safety that is an
important duty and there are
restrictions on the power of the
government to detain people or carry out
checks I have also competing duties I
have duties to ensure that people don't
become destitute so releasing people to
no fixed Abode or to no address is not
something that I'm willing to do I have
duties to the local community where
manston is I'm not willing to put in
Jeopardy people living in the local
community with uh you know migrant with
no no accommodation or no place to stay
that would not be a prudent use of
powers or duties for the local community
there are lots of competing and
challenging interests here in that
decision it is not a straightforward
well you know but the home office
lawyers on the 4th of October told you
that the home office does not have power
to detain while waiting for onward
accommodation and Welfare reasons that's
the specific advice that we understand
you were given on the 4th of October can
I just ask you then about this meeting
on the 19th of October this was the date
you resigned and in the letter to me you
say that as part of your meetings that
morning you had a critical operational
meeting about the developing situation
at manston can you just explain what was
that meeting about
well again I don't want to go into too
much detail about private government
matters but that does reflect the fact
that you know I was very aware of the
developing situation at manston we were
having almost daily meetings
um with Dan with General Stewart Skeets
who I put in place uh earlier in the
month to deal with the the crisis as I
did at manston to put up emergency
accommodation to provide uh shelter for
Utah coming in that meeting that you
were in breach of the law I'm not going
to comment as I said on the content of
legal advice that I've been given thank
you okay could I ask the permanent
secretary when did your officials notify
the Home Secretary that there was no
respectable legal argument to justify
the situation at manston
well without commenting on lead doctors
like I can confirm that the the home
office legal advice has been flowing
freely to to the Home Secretary
throughout throughout the time and
indeed to her predecessor um uh and and
predecessors and um and and that of
course will continue
okay because obviously the next day
um we have a New Home Secretary and that
Home Secretary says that um the home
office was uh in danger of breaching the
law and he took immediate action to
rectify the situation and he talked
about the no respectable legal argument
what's your question
I'm just listening to the permanent
secretary so by the by the 20th the
legal advice had changed
uh no the legal advice has been has been
consistent and uh I can confirm that
this Home Secretary and uh and other
Home secretaries have have uh been aware
of that advice and have taken it into
account in their decisions
oh so then so you're saying it was the
same legal advice to this Home Secretary
in her first tenure and then to Grant
chaps when he took a tenure his Home
Secretary
well the law didn't change I mean some
circumstances would have changed that
would have meant that updated legal
advice would be needed but but I mean
the the essence of the legal advice
would not change because it's uh it's
it's based on
um you know founding principles okay um
and just finally I just wanted to ask
you home secretary I know you've
explained that you came into post and
you were faced with this uh issue around
manston and the numbers coming across on
the small boats could you just say to me
could you just tell the committee
um
how did the home office get itself into
this mess with up to 4 000 people being
detained at manston who
is Home Secretary obviously you carry
the cam for this so is it your
responsibility is it previous Home
Secretary is it Grant shots for his
short tenure as Home Secretary whose
fault is it that we're that we have this
crisis well um I think that's a fair
question I'm not going to point the
finger of blame at any one person that's
it's not as simple as that uh as I've
been clear I arrived in full awareness
that there was a growing problem at
manston with the numbers arriving that's
combined with very limited uh housing
stock which is available to people to to
transfer them on from manston
um we've had uh you know we worked
incredibly quickly and intensively
during the month of September and
October and ever since to procure extra
accommodation and since the 6th of
September over a hundred new hotels
providing 9 000 additional bed spaces
have been brought into use uh there was
you know we had high levels coming in we
had have been aided by the fact as Dan
says by very low levels of people
arriving and that's given us
listen I don't think this is a I don't
think it's helpful to point the finger
of fault to anyone I'll tell you who's
at fault yeah it's very clear it's the
people who are breaking our rules coming
here illegally exploiting vulnerable
people and trying to abuse the
generosity of the British people that's
who's at fault but as Home Secretary in
terms of making the system work and the
processing center at manston there was
clearly a big problem so I'm just trying
to work out who was responsible for not
foreseeing that problem not dealing with
that problem who who was it were you
responding what's the Home Secretary I
do take the responsibility ultimately
for the performance of the home office
that is my job and that is my uh
responsibility but I'm yours I'm very
clear at who's at fault it's the people
coming here illegally people Smugglers
uh people who are choosing to take an
illegal and dangerous journey to come
here for economic reasons they are not
they should not be doing that and that's
who's at fault here we are trying we are
responding to a problem okay caused by
other people we are procuring as fast as
uh possible within our resources here
what you're saying to identify that
accommodation but the process that's
what I'm interested in the home office
process did not work it failed so I'm
just trying to work out why that was and
who was responsible
because these numbers were foreseeable
hotels were available why did you end up
with a position of 4 000 people at
manston
I think I've said everything I need to
say that we had a Confluence of
unprecedented numbers here we've worked
intensively to procure extra
accommodation I put in place General
Stewart Skeets uh in October to help us
grip the situation and operationalize it
he's worked very closely with Dan and
other colleagues we still have to cry to
improve the
um the the capacity at Madison and
thankfully largely because of that very
intensive effort that I oversaw but also
because of zero uh inflow we've been
able to get the numbers down to zero
okay but there was still a major crisis
at the side okay Tim Lawton thank you
chair homesickly welcome to the
committee we're a very friendly
committee uh really awesome can I ask
you one General um question that I want
to go into the recent uh increase in
numbers coming across the channel let's
do a bit of role play I'm a 16 year old
orphan from an East African country
escaping a war zone and uh religious
persecution and I have a a sibling
legally in the United Kingdom at the
moment what is the safe and legal route
for me to come to United Kingdom
um well we have uh you're fleeing which
country sorry any African country any
African country well be any continent
but let's say any African country I
don't want to name one because then the
Prime Minister might have a goat before
demonizing their population so let's
just theoretically talk about an African
country which is going through a period
of turbulence which is persecuting its
citizens including an innocent 16 year
old like me
well we have
um an asylum system and people can put
in applications for Asylum how would I
do that
well you can
um uh you can you can do it uh through
the safe and legal routes that we we
have we have offered 390 000 places uh
to people seeking safety from various
countries around the world we're not
Syrian I'm not Afghan I'm not Ukrainian
not to any of those specific schemes the
dub scheme is historic what schemes open
to me well if you are able to get to the
UK you are able to put in an application
for Asylum I would only enter the UK
illegally then wouldn't I well that that
would if you put in your application for
Asylum uh upon arrival that would uh be
the process that you enter how could I
arrive in the UK if I didn't have
permission to get onto an aircraft
legally to arrive in the UK let me just
invite other colleagues if there's
anything they want to add I mean
you could engage with you and actually I
mean depending which country you're from
you could engage with you in HCR and
that would be a way of of uh of um of uh
facility
um leave to enter the UK in order to put
in an asylum claim but I accept that
there are some countries where that
would not be possible I think the point
is that
as a shortage of safe and legal routes
other than for
specific groups of people that we have
generally offered Safe Haven to but let
me come on to the
recent increased numbers coming across
the uh the channel over you've said it's
unprecedented 40 000 people come across
the channel trying to enter the UK
clandestinely in that that way almost a
third have come from Albania and that
figure of over 12 000 is up from just 52
years ago why do you think they are
trying to come to the United Kingdom
um well I think I should say the answer
that we do value uh our relationship
with Albania and the Albanian community
in the United Kingdom and we continue to
welcome those albanians who travel to
the UK legally and who contribute
significantly to British Society uh we
are seeing as you say large numbers of
Albanian largely men risking their lives
uh making this dangerous journey to come
here through illegal means your question
is why
um I might ask Dan because he is
literally on the front line and he is
dealing with uh many people coming uh
coming through firsthand we've seen a
variety of claims made by albanians we
see a lot of them making modern slavery
claims claiming to have been victims of
trafficking we see a lot of Albanian
people making Asylum claims despite the
fact that you know
Albania is not a a country in conflict
or in uh
War I I I I think I think I've seen some
journalism recently that has
um identified Albanian people who've
come and who have of their own admission
said that they are coming for economic
reasons so I think there's a mixture of
reasons why but none of those are
reasons why they need to come to the UK
rather than another safe country if if
Albania is not a safe country which um
we think it is and uh EU countries think
it is so how come we have over 12 000
Albanian citizens applying for asylum in
most cases or being victims of so-called
modern slavery uh in others and yet
Germany and Sweden for example will not
recognize any Asylum claims from Albania
why are we not following suit
yep well I think that I mean so
Albanian Nationals have been one of the
nationalities most frequently referred
to the National referral mechanism the
most frequently in fact yes absolutely
uh since it was established in 2014 and
um they are the most common nationality
referred uh uh which is continuing that
Trend uh yeah you've asked why are we
not uh dealing with albanians in the
same way as uh other European
counterparts I think there are a mixture
of reasons uh when we make international
comparisons
um and it's not necessarily
straightforward as saying well you know
Germany presumes Albania it doesn't
accept Asylum claims from Albania they
might have just a threshold or a it
doesn't it doesn't recognize someone
claims from Albanian orders at Sweden so
why are we so different from those two
countries that we are entertaining over
12 000 people most of which have got
Asylum clones from a stable country if I
may I mean one of the really important
things to say about
um Germany and other countries like that
of course they're in the Schengen area
and um and there are land borders
between uh Albania and those countries
so it certainly wouldn't be true to say
that there aren't a lot of Albanian
people working illegally in the in those
countries albeit the silent ground rate
is very low I think that you know the
difference between that and the small
boats phenomenon is that we have a very
large number of people turning up at one
location in Dover who are then because
of the level of control we have over
those arrivals are then forced to make a
decision about whether they claim Asylum
or not that the grant rate for a site uh
for Asylum for Albanian males is
actually very low in the UK it's about
12 so suddenly you know if you look at
it in the round including families and
that sort of thing it is higher but it's
it's certainly not okay not true to say
that there isn't a similar problem and
the whole sector is absolutely right
because of because of the issue with the
uh National firm referral mechanism
um uh scheme and the way that it's being
exploited um and uh that that is an
incentive for and I understand we we
treat our bangers coming here
differently to other um countries the
overwhelming of the migration system
recently and particularly an impact on
manston I think we all agreed is largely
due to the very large increase in short
space of time of a group of albanians so
if the acceptance rate is so low and we
do accept assignment claims how many
albanians have been removed to Albania
out of those 12 000 Plus have come this
year 800 last year 50 the uh um before
how many applications for victims of
modern slavery have been accepted and of
those that have been accepted how many
have been removed back to Albania having
recognized their claims of being victims
of modern slavery which does not require
us to act then as host in the United
Kingdom to those people
and so I can give you some of those
numbers
um so there have been a thousand
um albanians returned uh to Albania um
who are foreign National offenders and
and the like since the agreement that we
signed with Albania last year National
offenders and the like how many of those
are not National offenders I'm only
concerned about okay
albanians that have come through
Manchester in the last few weeks we've
removed 36 of those directly back to
Albania and you may have read the
interview with with one of them in the
BBC this week which I thought was very
compelling
um
there have been uh
2916 Albanian referrals uh to the nrm uh
to August 2022 uh this year which will
include all of those uh arriving quite a
small boat okay so the the point to come
back to your home secretary a very large
portion of albanians who have a very low
success rate on Asylum claims and who
may have a higher success rate on not
modern slavery claims but do not require
to be kept in the United Kingdom indeed
a case could be made that they are safer
back amongst friends and family and
being protected by their own government
rather than subject to people
traffickers and the slavers in the
United Kingdom who are con controlling
them a very small portion have actually
been removed we have a special
arrangement with Albania set up by the
previous Home Secretary last year
what is that actually achieved how many
albanians have officials from the police
or their equipment to border Falls are
currently stationed in the United
Kingdom and aiding in the Speedy removal
of albanians and what measures are you
taking to fast-track albanians on the
basis that we all I think recognize that
they aren't in most cases genuine Asylum
Seekers who need to be kept in the
United Kingdom
multitude of questions there but I'm
sure a lot of questions there well I
think that
um
I mean I think this is part of the
problem that we're trying to fix is a
high number of people coming from
Albania making Asylum claims and making
modern slavery claims and and the the
reality is that our legal framework is
um is allowing those claims to be made
and then processed and you can really
see that when it comes to Modern slavery
uh you know a few years ago it would
take on average approximately 40 days uh
before a decision would be made on
Modern slavery grounds and now because
the system has been overwhelmed uh
largely by people coming here illegally
on small boats it's now taking over 400
days so uh yeah and and the law in our
modern slavery act obliges
um the the state to carry out an
assessment as someone's modern slavery
claim so that is
one of the challenges that we are facing
legally and a very high number of people
coming here from Albania are claiming uh
legislation
um are claiming
um you know rights which are provided
for in our legislation what have you
done about legal duties this was a
problem a year ago and it was identified
as a problem by your predecessor and
specializations were made with Albania
since when the number of albanians
coming here has gone up by multiple of
15. so what have you done and what did
your precessor do to make the situation
any better because it's got 15 times
worse
well there has been well I mean in terms
of what I am doing uh well perhaps you
or Dan want to talk about the returns
agreement struck with Albania and how
that's actually played out so let me let
me let me add other companies what home
search did so first of all we have uh
enforced a return of over 2 300 uh
people to Albania since 2019 uh just
last week we returned another 26
including some straight from manston has
done was uh describing uh we are working
very closely with our colleagues from
Albanian as the Home Secretary said we
have a shared interest in preventing
this sort of uh what is that migration
into the UK we have a shared interest
we're working closely what does that
mean well I'm now being into here how
many are there any officials are in this
country at the moment working the home
office or border Force and we we work
really very closely both in the UK and
and in Albania with officials right from
um uh the the front lineup to the
ministerial level and we've we have an
Albanian police officer who's deployed
at manston actually on the ground my
team's work very closely with um the the
embassy uh in the UK okay so there's one
of the big corporations there's one
Albanian police officer at manston who
presume at the moment is not got much to
do because it's empty how many other
Albanian police officers are Albania
officials are in the UK at the moment I
I mean I don't have the exact number but
what I can say is ten hundred and one a
thousand roughly we'll get an answer to
Mr Lawton but what I can speak to is the
extremely high level of very
constructive operational cooperation
okay um
announced by the previous Home Secretary
was that we would be working very
closely with the Albanian authorities
there was a streamlined agreement to
return those who had not got legitimate
claims and that officials would be boots
on the ground and working alongside UK
officials co-located in order to help
that process so far we've identified one
who's here I don't believe there are any
others here
Commander I'm on Amani you know probably
how many there are here because you're
working with all these people there
aren't any more here are there there's
one at Mountain and that's it sorry I
don't agree with that Mr slaughtered I
don't know the exact number but I know
that my my team are meeting with uh with
um officials from from the embassy and
from the uh diplomats I'm talking about
border officials and police officials
specifically posted over here as
announced by our previous Home Secretary
last year as a beefed up measure to deal
with the immediate and growing problem
of albanians coming here without due
processes I think the important thing
from my point of view is the operational
impact of what we're doing so there is
live data exchange going on between the
UK and teams in in torana on um uh
albanians who arrive in the UK both on
their documents and
um progressing to taking their biometric
details to see if they have criminal
records records in Albania that is a
very very impactive move and we have a
police officer deployed in Manson who is
helping us with the cultural awareness
and the understanding of of exactly who
these people are and what their likely
intentions are the operational impact of
that is is is is is uh really
significant and I think that you know
giving you a number probably underplays
that really significantly because well
particularly when we look at the
cooperation others who want to come in
can you answer the specific question of
how many albanians who've had a claim
processed and I realize that many still
in the system for modern day slavery
have had that claim upheld but they have
been located back to Albania because
it's been deemed safe to do that have
any
I've been relocated back to Albania
after that claim has been determined in
that way so I've I've I've I I look into
the number of Albania returns and the
total number of people that we return to
Albania since November 2021 is 1435.
that's the number that I've been given
here but what I would say in answer to
your questions to why notwithstanding
our agreement with Albania we are still
finding it difficult that that number is
is very small compared to the number of
people actually arriving here why is
that why are we not able to return more
Pursuit into our agreement the reason is
that if uh someone from Albania has a
legal claim pending whether it be modern
slavery or Asylum that trumps any
agreement we may have with Albania and
actually understand that it was a
specific question have anybody with
modern slavery claims being returned to
Albania I believe the number is zero if
that's wrong will you please write to us
to tell us because your officials
confirmed when Commander money was here
in a recent session that determination
of a modern day slavery claim is not
then leading to a mandatory Grant of
leave to remain in the United Kingdom
and there are reasons why they could be
more safely than protected by being
returned to Albania and I would hope
that part of the agreement would
facilitate that perhaps if we could be
told if that is happening because I
suspect it's not thank you Jeff thank
you Diane Abbott
um thank you very much chair
oh
it's about the migration and economic
development program agreement with
Rwanda which was announced earlier this
year
we know that you've been quoted as
saying I would love to have the front
page of the telegraph with a plane
taking off to Rwanda that is my dream
it's my obsession do you know what
happened when Israel tried this
well I mean we can always look to
International comparisons and I think
it's a very mixed picture when you look
at how different countries have tried to
deal with the complex challenge of
illegal migration
so if you're asking about what my view
is of our agreement with Rwanda I'm very
committed to it do you know what
happened
when Israel did this because this is
your dream this is your obsession I
would have thought that you would have
looked into what happened when other
countries tried to do it well I do know
that Israel I don't know the details but
I do know that Israel had some kind of
uh arrangement with Rwanda it was
tentative but it it didn't ultimately
work I also know that other countries
have had more successful uh analogous uh
experiences if you look at Australia for
example they did have uh a very
multifaceted approach to their challenge
with their uh illegal migration and when
they were able to start removing people
to another a different part of the
territory they uh yeah that was a
partial factor in um their ability to
combat the problem so I think there's a
very mixed picture if you look at
International examples what I'm focused
on is our UK experience I think that the
agreement that the UK struck with
rwanda's groundbreaking it is in both
our country's interests it is something
that uh is it will take us forward we
are currently engaged in litigation on
on the issue but um I'm very confident
that we will be able to operationalize
it uh as soon as possible
you said that Israel only sent a few
people no I didn't say that no I said
ultimately I don't think
sorry how many people do you think
Israel sent I don't know the exact
figures all right well the Israel
Israeli scheme was between 2014 to 2017
they sent thousands of people over there
but when Israeli researchers went
through under in 2018
what they found was of those thousands
of people only seven remained so it
wasn't very successful was it home
secretary
well I've been outside and there's
anything you want to say but I I I note
the Israeli example
um you know I don't think that
necessarily has to dictate what the UK
experience will be this is a different
agreement this is in a different set of
circumstances uh and we have been very
clear that we are confident about the
terms of our agreement with Rwanda and
I'm very confident about the effect that
it will have
well can I ask you are you also
confident that Rwanda is a safe country
to send people to
well I I I have actually visited uh
Rwanda twice
um quite quite a while ago
um uh um around 2010 2009 and um uh and
I'm I've always found Rwanda to be a
very inspiring country actually uh we
would only ever work with countries that
uh we assess to be safe and that we
assess will treat Asylum seekers in
accordance with relevant human rights
law and our own safety assessment of
Rwanda and their Asylum process has
found that it is fundamentally a safe
and secure country with a track record
of supporting uh Asylum Seekers so and
that is reflected in our country policy
information note which is published on
our government website are you aware
Home Secretary that Human Rights Watch
and the U.S state Department which is
scarcely somebody who you can ignore
they have said that the things that
single are under out is arbitrary
detention ill treatment torture and
official and unofficial detention which
is commonplace and fair trial standards
are routinely flouted are you saying the
U.S state Department is wrong
well Rwanda I I mean the facts are that
Rwanda already hosts hundreds of
thousands of refugees from the region
the U.S state Department is wrong well
our evidence and our view and our
assessment of the Safety and Security of
Rwanda is different we we say looking at
rwanda's track record
um and our assessments
um that actually as I say Rwanda already
hosts uh is a safe and secure country
with a track record of supporting over a
hundred and thirty thousand refugees
including through the UN Refugee agency
who they themselves said the country has
a safe and protective environment for
refugees
um so yeah we we would only work with
countries who have a safe uh and secure
uh basis for accommodating Asylum
Seekers and there's nothing in the UN
Refugee convention which prevents
removal to a safe country so you while
dismissing human rights War and the U.S
state Department just trying to get it
clear you're just missing what they have
to say I I don't I haven't seen their
documents and their views I don't really
want to comment specifically on the
content before you became Home Secretary
in saying that you 100 supported the
scheme
I do I do support the scheme there has
been rigorous investigation into the
arrangements and the conditions in
Rwanda Rwanda will process claims in
accordance with its International
obligations under the UN Refugee
convention it will ensure protection
from inhumane and degrading treatment as
I say it has already and is already a
safe and is already a safe and Secor
country
for refugees from the region and it
hosts the EU funded unhcr emergency
Transit mechanism so I don't think those
are institutions that would use Rwanda
for those purposes if there were serious
doubts about its viability
and are you confident that you can send
migrants there who are unwilling to go
the policy that we have put in place
when it comes to Rwanda is that uh they
will
um be moved there and their Asylum claim
will be determined in Rwanda understand
the policy put in place I'm asking you
something quite specific are you
confident that you can send migrants
there if they are unwilling to go
and you're aware that in the um when in
the Israelis tried uh tried this in 2017
the Israeli Supreme Court Struck it all
down saying you simply could not send
people unwillingly I I accept that's the
um Israeli Supreme Court but it's not
irrelevant to what you're trying to do
so you're telling this committee that
you're completely confident that you can
send migrants to Rwanda unwillingly I
just want it on the run it's not for me
to comment on the rights or wrongs of
another Sovereign Nations laws and
arrangements and I respect the Israeli
Court decision and their Arrangements in
a sense you're diverting from my
question
are you able to go on the record in
front of this committee and say that you
can send migrants to Ander if they are
not willing to go well I mean the whole
purpose of the scheme that we set up
with Rwanda is to send people there who
have arrived here illegally for their
Asylum crimes to be processed whether
they are willing or unwilling they will
either put in a legal claim and that
will be upheld or it will be dismissed
and that's the basis upon which if we
have the legal basis to do so we will we
will deliver the Rwanda scheme as fully
as possible
there are many other members that want
to want to put questions I'm just going
to ask you for the last time are you
confident that can legally send migrants
to anger who are unwilling to go what I
would say is I mean we are in the
process of litigation at the moment
there are live legal questions which are
going to be resolved by a cause
um you know let's wait to see what the
court says and what the outcome of
litigation is it wouldn't be you know
we've made our decision very clear in
court we have confidence in the Rwanda
scheme and you know if if we are
successful in litigation then we will be
delivering the Rwanda scheme at PACE
thank you just before I come to Stuart
McDonald perhaps the opponent secretary
might be able to tell us whether he is
now satisfied of the value for money of
the Rwanda scheme because uh he
obviously got a ministerial uh Direction
uh on the point of value for money we
understand another 20 million pounds has
been spent so perhaps um you're able to
confirm whether you've now reached a
conclusion on that or not
well I keep that judgment under constant
review as you would expect and the
circumstances have not changed
sufficiently for me to to change my
judgment which from April as you will
recall was that we did not have evidence
that it would be value for money which
is not the same thing as saying it will
not be value for money it was just we
were waiting to see what the evidence
would be as you have said
um uh the UK has paid 120 million plus
and now an additional 20 million for
setup costs uh to the government of
Rwanda
um and it Remains the case that it could
be value for money and it could not be
uh I will con I will repeat my
commitment to this committee and to your
assistant committee the Public Accounts
committee to update you when uh when the
circumstances change to to requiring to
change that assessment I will look
forward to that okay but I think it is
worth underlining that the purpose of
the scheme is deterrence it's prevention
the success of the scheme will not be
measured in how many thousands of people
are relocated to Rwanda but more in how
many thousands of people do not make the
dangerous crossing of the channel
putting their own in other people's
lives at risk that is that is the key
metric to determine uh on value for
money whether whether the scheme is
successful or not and clearly the
numbers have been going up this year
since the announcement at Stuart
McDonald thank you welcome everybody
um I want to talk about children in the
Asylum system but first of all just a
couple of quick factual
um follow-ups from earlier discussions
when we visited manston on the 8th of
November my notes tell me that the rare
at that stage 1292 people there does
that sound about right
okay so would it be possible for you
then to to write to the committee with
details about how many people were in
manston each day
um say from about the middle of August
that would be very helpful
um because it has been a frustration
that parliamentary questions for myself
and for my colleagues haven't been
answered and so if you can do that
that'd be very helpful indeed
um secondly
um Mr Romani so you're speaking a little
bit about the exceptional circumstances
um the Justified extended detention a
little on
again my recollection from a visit was
that we were essentially told that that
process had been abandoned for for a
certain period so where are you saying
that these were the exceptional
circumstances that justified really
abandoning that policy or are you seeing
there was a decision made on every
individual case to extend their
detention and reasons were noted down
and Authority sought from the
appropriate level of Officer
I'm not commenting on the legal uh
advice or the legal status for the
reasons that the Home Secretary has
already outlined so what I was
illustrating were the choices that we
were having to make
you know the choice about people staying
there for longer than 24 hours versus
especially there was a a call to be made
do I make dispute the extent to which
his attention between these two duties
I'm just asking as a matter of fact
where the home office in a position
whereby essentially had to stop going
through that process and just to say
well people are gonna have to stay here
for 20 days 30 days however long it
takes us to find accommodation I don't
know if you can come in Mr aircraft
so people Trail if I was would I be able
to see people seeing in each of these
cases I have sought Authority from the
appropriate level of Officer to extend
attention my understanding from her
visit was that was just abandoned
because it was Impractical we're gonna
have to go away look at that because I I
wasn't aware that you were told that
during the visit so I'll I'll have to
check the audit trainer to come right I
picked up wrong but the useful just to
have Clarity in that in the logistical
relation to albarians obviously there is
an issue but in terms of context I think
I'm writing saying that the latest
figures are 55 of Albanian Asylum claims
are accepted obviously there's a huge
disparity between women and women yeah
um also so we've spoken about the modern
slavery system as well I mean it's the
home office itself that the first people
into the national referral mechanism so
it's not as if people can make spurious
claims and somehow enter that system 97
of those claims are accepted
um and what is it that home office
guidance says about
um
conditions for victims of trafficking in
Albania and how Albania lives up to its
obligations under International
conventions I don't know if you can
comment on that Mr aircraft but I think
I think we I think it is fair to say
that we do have evidence that the system
is subject to abuse because you can see
that that the time at which in in one in
an individual process when they make the
claim to be a victim of modern slavery
and and you know very regularly it is
only at the point when their Asylum
claim would otherwise be broadcast
of that you know I mean it's well
established that
um victims of modern slavery will take a
long time to disclose these things and I
mean who on Earth is aware of the modern
slavery legislation when they first
arrive in the country you know so it's
not it's not as simple as seeing they
made that claim at the end of the time
here you're still accepting that 97 of
them are actually victims of modern
slavery well as as
um uh like the Home Secretary
um was discussing with Mr Laughton
earlier I mean the the big difference in
the UK's system and say German is is the
uh National referral mechanism the one
Avery Act is very victim focused and
gives very significant rights to victims
and that is good for genuine victims but
it does mean that it is
genuine victims 97 percent
correct
I don't I don't recognize that figure
but I but I but it is definitely open to
it is definitely open to abuse and and
so the government is looking at ways to
address evidence in because that's what
Paul can ask him for I mean the the last
trafficking
um commissioner that was imposed was to
wait for a reappointment says nope no
evidence of this it will provide the
evidence
and and you can come back to me if you
if you think my name is said something
as well about what we've learned from
the Practical experience is that um I
think the the
Grant rate is high we can get back to
you on the specific numbers
inclusive rounds right the final
decision
it is is high
um but what I would also say is um I
think there is there is evidence of
abuses it's not just in this code
well I'll also give you some examples I
mean we also see it in when it comes to
foreign National offenders you know
people who've been incarcerated after uh
serving sentences for serving for very
serious very serious crimes and you know
after many many years on the point of
removal it's interesting that they
suddenly remember that there are now
victim of on slavery and I perceive that
when you are a fellow immigration lawyer
as well uh in your past life you know I
I I I do see that as an abuse I'm afraid
I'll listen to you when you're able to
show me that these people were aware of
the right to claim to be victims more
than uh slavery earlier on in the
sentence and then we may be able to
agree in that but anyway I went to turn
to children because I'm using up all my
time on supplemented questions
um so I think we'd all agree on the
importance of deciding who is a child is
very very important there is obviously a
refugee Council report that suggested 97
94 of a cohort that they worked with
successfully challenged home office
assertions that children were adults
various other reports don't have as high
a figure as that but they're certainly a
big suggestion that the home office gets
this wrong far too often the problem I
have is that the home office doesn't
seem
to follow through and record what
exactly happens with um age assessments
that are challenged
what's your view on that Home Secretary
can't I think there's more we can do in
terms of gathering data surely we could
agree on that
well we I I've been interested in the
age assessment
processes when it comes to Asylum
seeking children
um and
um so typically the UK receives over 3
000 Asylum claims from unaccompanied
Asylum seeking children every year
between 2016 and 2021 there were six
thousand over six thousand cases where
age was disputed and subsequently
resolved with 58 percent
found to be adults I consider that to be
quite a high proportion but that's of
people claiming to be children and
subsequently being found to be of course
it is but my problem is as I understand
that that figure says it's 50 home
office decide our adults and then
actually when you go through the the
challenge
um we don't know how many end up
actually been found to be children
because you don't take a central note of
that so from
that cohort of the refugee Council 94 of
those that you have deemed to be adults
actually are children although as I say
don't have as high a figure as that but
you don't have any record of that you
just assert the home office has decided
that 50 odd percent are adults and
that's all you know Mr I Croft it Am I
Wrong
we're changing that system and the
nationality borders that brought in a a
a new uh approach of a national age
assessment board which went after
commencement of those provisions of that
acts will uh uh consist of expert social
workers whose task will be to deduct age
assessments uh against a local Authority
refers just vital for our ability to
know whether or not the home office is
getting this right that you guys so you
say 50 of these folk we think are adults
but then you also need it's not it's not
just someone just sort of you know
plucking a judgment out of the air is
that there is that there is a there is a
process that has gone through with
experts have concerns about that process
we'll come to them a little upsetting
but um but you don't record what
actually happens at 58 of them or sorry
94 in that particular cohort were
eventually found to be so surely we can
at least agree that you should have a
central database of that so we can
assess whether home office is doing its
job properly
I just ask you to look at that and
surely that's something we agree would
be useful to know is is our home office
assertions that people are adults
actually standing up to scrutiny my that
suggests absolutely not so surely if you
want to combat my view you have to say
no that's not right because we have
followed this through and actually the
home office decisions have been uphilled
in 85 well it comes down to as a
permanent saying that the rules that are
being applied yeah at
um facilities like manston when people
arrive they claim to be a child they go
through some checks those checks
ultimately resulting in 58 of them not
being to be
well-founded claims to be children we
are that according to the nationality
and borders act does bring in new
guidance more rigorous approach to trade
assessment that's according to two
border guards who speak to them for 40
minutes I have to say I was not
impressed with that aspect of Madison's
a lot perfectly understand at Madison
but I didn't I didn't wasn't impressed
by that have you investigated the claims
that children arriving at manston were
pressured into saying that they were
encouraged to see that they were adults
so that they would go to hotels a game
comes from the refugee council with a
recording of a conversation
with a an immigration officer no I
haven't heard I don't recognize that
there's encouragement by officials to
make particular claims what I do know in
terms of the data is uh the breakdown by
age of unaccompanied Asylum seeking
children the vast majority of
unaccompanied assigned children are 16
or 17 years old
um that 90 of them are male that I just
offer that as for factual context yeah
but back to my my questions Mr raycroft
has anything happened as a result of
those allegations was there an
investigation or any guidance issued
I'll have to jack that specific question
Mr McDonald but what I can say is that
clearly there are some incentives for
some people who are actually adults to
claim to be children and there are other
incentives for other people who are
actually children to claim to be adults
and we want to
um uh to to to to to to to reduce both
of those
is it your policy at the moment to be
placing each disputed children into
hotels
well we um our policy is that children
people who claim to be children uh uh we
have a responsibility for them and
ultimate and ideally uh our aim is for
children and unaccompanied Science
teaching children to be placed through
local authorities into foster care uh
unfortunately there is a national
shortfall of available foster care
placements and therefore we do have to
put
um as a a default option on a computer
science interesting children in uh into
hotels they are when they are in those
hotels supported by team leaders support
workers social workers and we try and uh
you know
a lot of support for for these children
it we seem to be struggling to
understand what it is they're supposed
to do so for example if a security guard
is spoken to by somebody at hotel or
migrant help get a call from somebody
who's at a hotel and they say I am a
child and to ngos and these people seem
to not be absolutely clear what is
supposed to happen at that stage
but if they are Children's Home
Secretary said there is a there is a a
very significant uh amount of wraparound
support that is available including
Education Health safeguarding and and
other expertise from people whose
full-time job it is to to provide that
support if somebody hasn't been able to
access that then who do they call attack
well they they they they have a rights
to access that and they should access
that and I and I think that their route
to uh to ensure they are accessing that
would be through migrant help I think
but it would depend on the precise
circumstances the particular local
Authority they were in and so on is
there a specific safeguarding policy for
children
uh yes okay and and what does it say in
relation to who children can share with
in hotels because I think that's quite
clear rules around who can share with
who in the special accommodation but I
can't find them in relation to hotels
okay we can we can check that and and
write to you as well and then finally um
I know you can't say very much about
[Music]
um
the the death at Manson obviously
absolutely understand because I first of
all ask what steps have been taken to
support uh staff there because they've
been a traumatic experience for them
also
um other detainees and also seek
assurances that those who may have
information about what happened uh been
kept track of and there was an incident
obviously where
um almost got in trouble for removing
people who might have had information
relevant in question so you could
reassurances that will not be happening
in this case so I missed your second
question Mr McDonald so so the support
and then secondly just assurances that
anyone who might have information about
what happened isn't being removed
frankly or lost sight of because there
was an incident a couple years ago where
I think the home office had been the
subject of some criticism for that
happening
and there's a very high level of welfare
support available to
um my officers and the contractors that
work at manston including on uh well not
on site but close to the site and
counseling support and and a range of
other
um uh arrange other officers so the
welfare support is is a strong offer I
mean in in terms of um other people
involved there's there's an ongoing uh
Colonial uh uh inquest uh into the
circumstances
um uh but what I can say is you know the
the person involved
um it had a significant level of medical
support while he was staying at manston
and and the circumstances around uh what
happened are not suspicious in any way
uh so there's no police investigation on
ongoing
um but of course we we're very mindful
of um the people that he was with uh the
fact that as far as I understand it we
haven't managed to contact internet of
kin yet
um so very tragic circumstances that
we're continuing to handle very
carefully thank you
just on that point how long was that
that man who sadly died at manston how
he arrived in the UK on the 12th um and
he died in the early hours of the 19th
he was at Manchester
I'm not surprised
thank you uh Simon fell
Sharon thank you very much to the panel
for joining us
um I'd just like to ask a few questions
on the Asylum backlog if if I may
um so my understanding is that the
backlog sits at around 122 000 people at
the moment waiting for an initial
decision
um that breaks down to around 70 000
we've been waiting for a year or under
40
000 for one to three years and around
ten thousand who've been sat in the
system for three to five years
um we heard from officials during our
last session on this that only about
four percent of applications submitted
in 2021 had received a decision within
six months
um and we've got figures from
um the immigration Minister around the
number of people making those decisions
so about a thousand
um caseworkers who are working through
them at a case of about um two a week
um now my maths is pretty appalling but
um even I can figure out that needs
about a 250 increase to to maintain that
backlog at its current levels
um so first question is the obvious one
what's your plan to start to reduce that
backlog
yes well
um I agree that there is a uh the
backlog is uh too higher too high and we
are developing comprehensive plans to
tackle and reduce the Asylum backlog uh
there are three primary mechanisms that
we aim to do that firstly increasing the
productivity of caseworkers by
streamlining digitizing and simplifying
the process through the delivery of our
transformation program and the PACE
program secondly tackling the Legacy
caseload in a balanced way and thirdly
the recruitment of new decision makers
and that Asylum transformation program
aims to bring the system back into place
and to modernize it uh you know uh four
percent of decisions being made is far
too low the average uh decision
the rate of decision making is one
decision a week per decision maker we
need to increase that
um and that's why we are increasing the
number of Asylum caseworkers
um and we've uh we've done that by 80
from 597 staff in 2019 20 to more than a
thousand today and we're on course for a
further 500 people by March of next year
which would take our total to
approximately 1500.
you know I thank you can I can I does
that take into account the I think it's
46 attrition rate you have no attrition
does mean that we are expecting to have
approximately 1300 caseworkers by March
next year after attrition year
so so based on that when do you expect
the backlog to start to be reduced
well I mean listen we're working uh to
to get it reduced as quickly as possible
I can't unfortunately put a precise date
on uh when we want uh uh this to be
regularized but uh we want to the the
rollout of the pace pilot
um to all home office sites is due to be
completed by May of next year and then
we want to roll that approach to a
further
um uh to to three further operational
sites and we want to deliver sustainable
changes to reach a minimum of three
decisions per decision maker per week by
May of next year but um the but with we
have an ambition of to reach four
decisions per decision maker per week
um so that is the current level of
ambition
I appreciate that and I appreciate it's
difficult but um there's still a huge
Delta between where you are and and
where you need to get to
um we've seen with other
similar circumstances you know the home
office work quite flexibly
um in these in a situation like this so
with Ukraine you stepped up
um a team from across the home office to
process visas when you had a backlog
um we had the same with the EU
settlement scheme I'm curious to
understand whether you might be thinking
of doing something similar here and
bringing people across some other parts
of the department to help work through
this
yes I'm I'm still very keen to explore
all options
um and so uh you know there has been
mounting pressure on the Asylum system
for several years uh because of the
numbers of people putting in Planes
um some of those claims do have complex
needs they have safeguarding measures
they have issues to do with age
assessment some people are very
vulnerable so uh if there's a modern
slavery claim that it requires uh more
resource so those those claims because
of our legal duties need to be
considered fully and robustly and that
takes time and that takes a certain
level of expertise so but but I agree
there is far too much delay in the
system it is too slow and there are
different
um elements within our overall Visa
Asylum decision making system where
decisions can be made in a in a much
quicker fashion and I'm very keen to see
what we can learn I'm looking at you
know how can and we try and uh you know
uh streamline using technology how can
we uh you know build on what the results
of the trial uh which we LED in Leeds uh
resulted in
um which did increase the average
decision-making rate so there are lots
of things we're looking at
yeah I won't lie it's not not easy
and I said could I just had two things
to to what the Home Secretary has said
so first of all on the uh on on the uh
on the productivity of each individual
caseworker all of the facts then
secretary said are are accurate I would
just add that that the training uh
investment is quite significant so it's
not as simple as just moving people off
one scheme and onto this it is it is
important that people have have full
training in order to get up to speed
which is why overall we have we have
dealt with the bulk of this through new
Recruitment and secondly retention is an
issue I mean these are amongst the
lowest paid uh civil servants in uh in
the civil service so we have found a way
of paying a retention allowance so that
if people stay uh for a a year they get
paid 1500 pounds more until they stay
for uh
in for two years or more than they get 2
500 and that is uh that is uh halving
the uh the leaving rate doubling the
retention rate and and I appreciate that
and obviously the the end result of this
backlog is six and a half million pounds
spent every day on on Hotel
accommodation so it would seem
prudent to spend money up front and get
more of these cases processed as as soon
as you can but but just just on your
point Home Secretary about
um looking at what you can do to
um expedite decision making you know
there's a case for being bold here so um
you know we've heard about the four
percent that have been processed if you
look at the the cohorts of people who
are sat in that backlog you know 35 of
them that's 43 000 people come from five
countries around Afghanistan Eritrea
Sudan and Syria
um Iranians have got a grant rate of
around 85 the other countries I
mentioned are close to 100 percent
isn't there a case to start to triage
and do security checks make sure people
who they say they are make sure that
um we can trust them and then allow them
to get into the country and earn money
get out of the home office support
system get out of hotels
curious as to your thoughts well I think
um
the view at the moment is that we don't
believe it's appropriate to prioritize
Claims One nationality over another as
many claimants irrespective of
nationality are potentially vulnerable
and no one is expected to leave the UK
while they've got a claim outstanding so
claims are prioritized on the basis of
current tasking within the department
the kinds of things we are looking at
however are
initiatives to reduce the time it takes
to interview and decide Asylum places is
there something around that process
which can sometimes take a very long
time that we can streamline we're
looking at trying to uh as I say double
double the the the decision-making Pro
improve the decision-making process so
there's less bureaucracy involved you
know on uh uh within the caseload of a
decision maker
um those are kind of things that we are
we're looking at but I I take your point
that there are definitely cohorts which
demonstrate particular features but I
think by identifying them by nationality
wouldn't be the right way to go and and
I completely understand the fairness but
I think we also need to look at
pragmatism here and you know if you can
reduce those numbers down by a third by
following this path if you follow Mr
Lawton's chain of logic you can reduce
that number down to almost half when you
take albanians out of the equation as
well that would severely reduce the
strain on statutory services in our
constituencies on third part on third
sector organizations on the hotels that
being used in the system and it would to
me make sense to to follow that path
um anyway that is
thank you I'm going to thank you very
much I'm going to take Caroline Harris
very quickly and then it is quickly um a
Home Secretary I wonder if you'd comment
on the reports that the people being
hired by the home office to clear the
Asylum processing backlog again in just
two days of training and that many of
them are getting that information about
the countries that people are fleeing
from from Lonely Planet and the Rough
Guide
that's that's a concerning report I'm
not not familiar with it but uh I yeah
I'm not sure if there's anything you can
say about the kind of training that
people are getting but ultimately these
are really important decisions that
people are making uh it's important that
they receive sufficient training that
they are using the appropriate guidance
um issued by government and uh verified
by uh independent expertise when these
decisions are being made so um we want
to ensure that our caseworkers are
properly remunerated and ensure that
they have the proper resources to to
work productively
and this and there's country guidance on
every country and that is the basis of
the caseworkers decision making okay
process
of securing accommodation and talkers
through the criteria
do you mean for an individual person no
I mean for the accommodation
um
you mean for an individual person
securing their accommodation what is the
process for securing a destination of
accommodation for someone who comes and
presents yes so what what criteria is
used when the home office secures
accommodation to move people from
manston to a hotel
well we we look at we look at
availability uh that that's been a key
factor for procuring accommodation we
um we want to ensure that people are
able to be properly supported in that
accommodation
um our our main uh priority is to use uh
dispersed accommodation through local
authorities and
um uh we provide a lot of funding to
make sure that eligible local
authorities can provide the wrap around
support locally more than 21 million
pounds has been provided in unring
fenced grant funding to those local
authorities and local authorities will
also receive 3500 pounds for each new
accommodation bed that they provide
through dispersal accommodation in this
financial year so we that's our main
priority we want to IDE ideally not use
hotels and go through the local
authorities to identify uh properties
that way
so
on the 20th of November
I received an email
from Asylum support swans command to
advise me that a hotel in my
constituency was going to be stood up
within 24 hours
the problem with bassets the size is not
a hotel it hasn't been for over 17 years
this is derelict
when I have gone back and asked a series
of questions which I believe to be
relatively easy questions such as
any planning or change of use
applications that have been made to the
local Authority number of proposed
Asylum Seekers for the property details
of the proposed Asylum seekers in terms
of the uh demographics so women men
children families any relevant risk
assessments regarding location profile
of people being placed there checks made
for human habitation on the property
fire safety gas safety special
requirements including overcrowding and
bathroom facilities sanitation length of
time but they will be held there
and information on how you intend to
support people in the accommodation with
meals Healthcare Security Finances Etc I
was told that that information was
complex
and was not readily available and they
couldn't meet the deadline of 24 hours
that I'd set and it may take 72 hours
do you think that's reasonable that that
information is not readily available
well so I don't know the particular
circumstances of what's happened in this
case but what I will say is that I am
aware of real concerns about the
procurement of hotels so as I've said
our main priority is to try to get
Asylum Seekers accommodated through
local Authority housing and when we
can't do that we are using hotels and
that is a short-term solution to meet
our immediate and acute need
we've also been we have providers who
are tasked with identifying suitable
options to ensure that these hotels are
made available you just asked me about
the criteria and I've got I've got the
detailed criteria here regarding the
hotels we Source the suitable
accommodation within the broad
principles of the standards so they need
to be of a suitable
contractual requirement the availability
we generally are using them on an
exclusive use but basis they need to be
suitable and that includes the impacts
on the local community the local
availability of local Services Community
cohesion feedback from local partners
and affordability and value for money
are also a criteria in within this
process and once a site is identified as
potentially viable
providers
the contractors with whom we work are
given the approval to begin due
diligence and engagement with the hotel
and the home office then begins its
engagement activity with local Partners
including notice to the local Authority
chief executive and the Member of
Parliament we are instituting this new
process because I am aware that it
hasn't been
given this particular site has not been
a hotel for over 17 years and is
derelict do you think that your due
diligence is working right well I I
don't know if there's anything you know
about this particular matter but I'm as
I say that does on the face of what
you're telling me sound concerning it
doesn't sound as if a Derek I mean of
course and again without knowing all the
facts a derelict uh piece of
accommodation would not be suitable
accommodation for Asylum Seekers or
anybody
for that fact so we um I I I don't know
what's happened there if I'm honest I
don't know if there's anything you can I
don't know about that specific case uh
literary but we will we will we will
follow up
um with you to make sure that the the
engagement that the homosexuals talk
about and the new system which we've set
up as of this week I hope you've seen
the letter from the minister for
immigration to all MPS that sets out
that process but that engagement
includes answers to all of your
questions and obviously if there's been
such a important misunderstanding as the
one that you described then clearly you
know that something has gone wrong in
the process I think a misunderstanding
is an understatement Mr I'm profit if
you don't mind me saying
um interestingly the local Authority
chief executive was advised that that
particular accommodation is now not
going to be used
and I have yes to have the courtesy of
that being sent to me officially
I'd like to contact concentrate on the
geographical spread
because
information that I have
which has been taken
um from the House of Commons library in
December 2021.
and this is specifically only looking at
section 95 of Asylum support so it's
only a proportion
of
immigration as a whole the total number
in the Northwest was 11
544 which is around 20 percent of all
placed Asylum Seekers and that gives a
ratio of 15 Asylum Seekers per 10 000 of
population
in comparison the southeast and
Southwest have a combined amount of
5696 Asylum Seekers which accounts for
around six percent of all those based in
uh in the country and a ratio of two per
ten thousand a population in both
regions
why local authorities in areas that have
been hit harder by austerity and are
already
um
one could describe as areas of
deprivation are being used
predominantly over the more leafy shires
for example
well I think you raise a very important
Point actually and I've been concerned
for some time about the disparity in the
distribution of
hotels and if we focus on hotels now but
actually you could say the same for
generally speaking Asylum accommodation
and um and the point that you make
for your local area I think you could
make in in relation to different areas
around the country there are some local
authorities who have a very high
concentration of hotels or Asylum
seekers in their vicinity and there are
some local authorities who are housing
zero Asylum Seekers now I've become
aware of this I don't think that I'm not
sure I don't understand the reason for
that in equal distribution and I know um
the uh ultimately it is we have
contractors who who identify the hotels
and actually procure them the
immigration Minister has been been
recently liaising very closely with
these Contracting companies to probe
more closely as to why there seems to be
such an inequal uh unequal distribution
and we I I want to understand whether
there is a rational decision for that
has it been an inadvertent consequence
um and that that is something I'm very
very much aware of when you get that
information are you then able to share
that with the committee please
well I I mean I I would want to be as
transparent as possible I don't want to
make a commitment where there might be
some uh procedural conventional bar to
me sharing uh commercial or sensitive
information but if there's anything you
want to add well I think we'll find
we'll find a way of sharing whatever it
is that we can that work is complete and
I I should add that in addition to a
clear inequality in terms of where
hotels are located there's also some
inequality in terms of the subsequent
accommodation because not every local
Authority uh was taking part in the in
the dispersal uh system which is why in
April the government introduced a full
mandated dispersal model requiring every
local Authority across the country to
take uh to take part in in order to to
get you know more of a fair share across
the whole country
I suppose finally for me then
um
if I look at my particular local
authority of Liverpool
I think it's safe to say and you know I
know the local Authority share my
my view on this and my frustration my
communications have been extremely poor
there is a failure by the home office to
utilize the relationships with the city
council
and
um
although Liverpool is a proud city of
sanctuary there is a or there should be
serious consideration on the impact of
unplanned placements on services and
Community cohesion
I don't think
that actually
is being done if I'm honest
um
the resources are incredibly stretched
in the city
um the contingency Hotel bed space is
not included in the new Asylum Grant and
I know that you've talked about
additional funding Home Secretary but
the contingency hotel bedspace is not
included in the new Asylum Grant so my
question
is Will additional funds be given to
local authorities such as mine in
Liverpool
to cover the costs of this because quite
frankly the city cannot be expected to
continue
to do this without the appropriate
funding and support
well again I sympathize with the point
that you're making on the communication
and I recognize that there has been to
date poor communication between the home
office and local authorities and members
of parliament when a hotel is about to
be used for Asylum Seekers and I think
that can be a very
um you know it's a big it's a big change
to a local community and I think it's
only fair that people are putting on
notice in the local area and that
there's liaison and there is preparation
time and that's why we've instituted a
change in the process I the letter of
the 18th of November from my ministerial
colleague the minister for immigration
Robert genre makes clear that we are not
happy with the level of Engagement we've
heard your frustration and we do want to
ensure that there are um there is a
better process in place that's why we've
committed to emailing uh MPS no less
than 24 hours prior to individuals
arriving emailing notification to the
local authorities prior to arrival we
want um much better written notification
of Our intention to use a hotel with a
fulsome fact sheet and a briefing pack
on Asylum and Asylum support and
accommodation we want more information
to be provided to you on the proposed
cohort and the actual people who are uh
within limits but about the people
coming because we accept that this
change
um uh can you know
this change can be very difficult for
local communities I'm going to have to
ask you to conclude there because we are
running out of time and I'm just very
conscious that we've still got members
who want to ask questions can I just say
um perhaps as a helpful comment that you
might want to look at some of your
contractors in terms of the hotel
accommodation that they
um commission and use it seems to me
patently obvious that the areas that
have the cheapest housing and hotel
costs are the ones that have the most
um Asylum Seekers so areas like
Liverpool Bradford Hull so that seems to
me a patently obvious reason why those
areas have got that concentration I'm
going to say very briefly I am also
aware I am frustrated by the issue with
hotels I have looked at what kinds of
hotels are being used I'm I don't find
it acceptable that in some instances we
are housing Asylum seeks in four-star
hotels because that's certainly not the
case
so we need to fix that okay thank you
Carolyn Harris thank you chair I'm going
to take you to a different subject
because I need to be in the chamber for
Welsh questions and I want to ask you
about
um if you're aware that the CPS this
week have dropped a case
um regarding several men or several
persons who've allegedly driven down the
Finchley Road earlier this year
chanting very very anti-semitic chance
at members of the Jewish Community who
were there
I understand the CPS is not within your
domain but the police said police are
and I'm asking if you will give
consideration to a review with how the
police and the CPS look at these kinds
of cases because currently we have
communities who are very scared very
concerned and very very
marginalized that this kind of behavior
has now gone completely unchallenged
um well I was aware of that report
although I don't know the details of it
and as you say there is an operational
Independence that the CPS possesses uh
it is also not under the home office
remit so there's very little I can say
about CPS decision to pursue or to drop
charges on an individual case
um what I do know is they will be
complying with the legal tests by which
they are bound and it whether whether it
is an evidential matter whether it's a
question of the the law I don't know but
there may well be a variety of reasons
on the broader issue
um I mean this is actually an issue very
close to my heart I I have members of my
own family who are Jewish and I really
sympathize with the uh you know the
incidence of anti-Semitic hate crime and
I I do share your concern that uh
enforcing against it uh is um you know
in in some regards not sufficiently done
um and this is why you know we have an
organization like CST which has come
into existence
CST they do fantastic work but the fact
that the Jewish Community has had to
fund and resource its own security
service because they have felt that they
have not been able to rely on public
policing and law enforcement is a very
sorry State of Affairs so
um let me take that issue away I'm not
going to commit to a full review there
are many many reviews going on at the
home office and they are all for very
important reasons but I I thank you for
raising that issue with me and one other
quick question which is around the
kilometer summer of for him his
Majesty's Passport office and at what
comments the Home Secretary may have on
the abysmal performance of
Teleperformance who at the end of July
there were 550
550 passports outstanding at best I
think people were being answered within
five hours including casework workers
from MPS who were trying to help and
support constituents very many calls
went unanswered the information that was
being handed out by telecommunications
was of no use whatsoever as it was com
they were completely unable to answer
questions around how long apart would be
where it was in the process and yet
Teleperformance went on to receive other
government departments
a huge amount of money has gone into
this company
is the Home Secretary convinced that
this was value for money that we are
Outsourcing at a time when we have a
cost of living crisis and that money
could have been spent in this country to
beef up our service and not Outsource it
well I read with interest over the
summer your reports about Visa
processing and I I noted carefully your
concerns about Teleperformance and I
arrived at the home office raising these
concerns
um because I wanted to get to the bottom
of the problem and I did not want to
repeat of the issue and I'm very glad to
say that now we have fixed the problem
actually there I would say I'm quite
confident in saying that we have now
resumed uh the service level and the
performance uh back to I think it's
something like the high 90 99 of our
issuances uh up to our minimum Service
uh standard uh and we have actually
emerged from that problem successfully
through a concerted effort of uh you
know resources and better streamlining
on your question about the contract with
Teleperformance
um
let me let me hand over to you see
whether you have any views on where we
were going with that just just say we we
shared your concern about
teleperformance's performance uh and we
used the uh contract that we had with
them uh to improve it uh and as long as
you said that did improve over the over
the summer and is now back within uh
acceptable standards uh and uh we have
put in place a series of measures um
since the home secretary's first arrival
uh in September to ensure that in 2023
we learned the lessons from 2022 not
just in relation to Teleperformance
which is the privatized part of the
passport operation but the whole of the
passport operation as well
thank you and what I would say to people
is one of the reasons why we had the
problem with visas earlier this is a
real um surge of applications I would
encourage people to get their
applications in early and not at the
last minute so we don't have a repeat of
uh applications have been in a long time
that's true as well this was all
entirely predictable as well can I just
ask is the standard processing time now
down to three weeks no no it's still at
10 weeks still it's still at 10 weeks we
haven't gone back to the standard
process so that we've worked really hard
so we've successfully managed the
delivery of our annual summer surge of
students and we are currently processing
student visas within the three-week
service standard priority visas and
super priority Visa services are still
available the general public it's not a
three-week standard it's Ten Weeks still
and could you write to us and tell us
how much Teleperformance actually paid
in penalties
yes for their poor performance thank you
Lee Anderson thank you chair
um I'm secretary this I'm going back to
small boats now uh this is now a massive
industry we have the gangs making
millions of pounds we have Circo making
millions of pounds hotels making
millions of pounds and some dodgy
immigration lawyers uh making millions
and pounds it is a massive massive
industry and this is because of the pool
Factor people coming here through
several countries uh because there's a
massive pull they picked up in the sea
they're driven to manston be processed
and then put in hotels and then
dispersed until we move the pull factor
is never going to stop and all these
dodgy groups are going to keep making
millions and millions of pounds at the
expense of the taxpayer and just last
week in the Midland Hotel in Mansfield
which looks after homeless people from
Mansfield and Ashfield Ashfield
residents my residents were turfed out
and illegal immigrants Asylum Seekers
were placed in in the hotel
what do I say to the people in Ashfield
who say to me this is absolutely
ridiculous we've got hard-working tax
paying people in Asheville paying their
raise paying their taxes helping to look
after our own homeless people and put
them in local hotels now they've been
turfed out to put people in who quite
frankly have been trafficked they've got
no right to be here and some of them are
criminals please tell me what I say Tom
well I I I agree that we are in a in a
crisis and um you know I don't think
it's uh fair to try and minimize the
challenge that we are facing or to
um to to to suggest that it's easy to
fix
um the reality is is that this is a
really complex Challenge and you're
absolutely right you describe it in the
right way this is largely criminal gangs
uh exploiting vulnerable people selling
a lie
um that they are going to get a better
life in the UK and people are uh you
know taking massive risks uh with their
own money with their own livelihoods to
to get here and they are breaking our
rules and they are abusing the
generosity of the British people and it
needs to stop and we need to fix this
problem the prime minister is absolutely
determined to fix it uh we are we need
to take a multi-pronged approach
um one of the issues we've touched on it
today is trying to fix our Asylum
backlog system because once we get
people processed quickly we can get them
out of hotels and we've talked a bit
about that we also need to change some
of our legal Frameworks frankly because
people are coming here and making
spurious claims of modern slavery or
Asylum and they are
gaining and buying time in the UK at the
cost of the British taxpayer so we need
to change some availability
because I know they're making spiritual
claims and and you know and most people
in the real world know they're making
spiritual claims what can we do because
an immigration law is never going to
admit it a claimant's never going to
admit it so how do we solve that problem
well uh we did announce earlier that we
are going to introduce legislative
measures I I can't go into the detail of
what that legislation is going to
include because uh discussions are still
live within government but there is a
need to make the rules more more robust
and the regime tighter
um and whether that's uh you know
effectively we want to send the message
that if you are coming here illegally
you will not be able to stay here you
know indefinitely in some cases or for a
very long period of time while your
Asylum claim is being processed and
there is a you know you're not allowed
to jump the queue you're not allowed to
play the rules so that's the regime we
need to set up the nationality and
borders act has made some progress in
getting to that point and some of it is
due to the operationalize and the age
assessments uh are one part of that
puzzle so the the legal changes will be
part of our solution we also need to
work with the prevention and the the
detection further upstream and Dan's
work you know with uh the National Crime
agency you talked a lot about the
criminal element of it there's been some
success between the the French
authorities and the UK authorities in
actually intercepting some of these
gangs arresting uh hundreds of the
individuals who who are facilitating the
criminal activity and actually resulting
in the disbanding of some of these gangs
so that's part of the problem that won't
fix it one more question object but it's
part of the problem part of the solution
of time
I've been told that hotels all over the
country are being offered twice as much
money
and to accept Asylum Seekers illegal
immigrants as they are to house homeless
people or just normal tourists is that
true
so I don't know the specific terms uh
containing the contracts relating to
particular hotels what I do know however
is that there has been a paucity of
supply of hotels which have been
available for this particular we were
told Home Secretary during covert that
the reason that immigrants were in
hotels was to stem the flow of the virus
to control the virus the virus is gone
now but we're putting more in hotels
body we're putting more in hotels
because we cannot procure enough private
rented accommodation via local
authorities let me just put a GM sector
we're putting more Intel's because we
are the home officers failed to control
our borders and it's not fit for purpose
at the moment well we have failed to
control our borders yes and that's why
the Prime Minister and myself are
absolutely determined to fix this
problem
can I just ask you um you said on the
floor of the house that legislation
would be introduced later this year and
we're just conscious there's only a few
days left until the end of this year so
is that still going to happen are we
going to see some legislation introduced
well I can't commit to a timeline today
I have to say but so but the legislation
will be introduced okay okay you did say
later this year's right well that's not
gonna happen I can't go into too much
here but there's lots there's been lots
of changes in government there's been
you know uh we are working at PACE to
introduce the legislation
um it you know ideally it would be by
the end of this year that may slip I
have to say okay thank you James Daly
thank you very much why can't decision
makers make 15 cases decide 15 cases a
week
well that's a very good question and one
that I myself have posed
um and uh uh what what we have found is
that there's a
um often the applications are incredibly
voluminous
um with their paperwork and the
um the the kind of substance that's put
into those claims and sometimes they
involve very complex issues quite
personal matters issues relating to
vulnerable people
um and what I've been told is it is uh
very difficult to make decisions at a
quicker at that kind of level
well I think that anybody looking at
this situation and then and perhaps Mr
icroft can tell me if I'm wrong the fact
that we've got to a situation where only
one decision per week was being made is
the height of ranking competence or bad
management
um and I think it goes to Mr Anderson's
point that the most basic
tasks are not being carried out any
anywhere near an efficient manner so Mr
Rucker can you just tell us what this
lack of productivity and the the grand
gesture that we need to get to three
decisions a week
I mean that is a scandal three decisions
a week in any other industry we would be
that would be laughable so can you
please give me some reassurance we're
going to get into more than that
so what what I can what I can do Mr
daily is to set out the differences
between a decision in relation to
someone's Asylum claim and other
decisions that other home office teams
are making day in day out which are much
more the volume that you're talking
about in fact much higher than that so
if you take another example the EU
settlement scheme for instance which
very successfully
um uh provided uh decisions on status
for I think over six million uh EU
Nationals decision makers in that team
on that scheme were taking I think you
know more than 15 decisions per day not
not even per week that's because it was
a very if compared to this a very simple
yes or no decision right but whereas
someone's Asylum claim is the Home
Secretary said it often comes with a
very significant set of paperwork which
depends crucially on not just the
circumstances in the country to which
they come from but also they're very
particular claims for persecution or
whatever it is I'm not denying that one
per one decision per case worker per
week is is too low it is much too low
um but it but it would be unreasonable
also to think you could get to 15 a day
in that world if I was looking if you
were to show me unless paper files
electronic files but a a file that a
decision maker has made whether it is to
Grant or not what would I see within
that file how many pieces of paper would
I say well you you there'd be a there'd
be a lot and it's not it's not just when
we talk about the decision we're also
talking about the things that go into
the decision including the interview
which takes up uh you know as many hours
and so let's go we've got the interview
what else have we got that's part of the
process you've got all of the uh you've
got all of all of the background about
uh about the country uh and the person's
claim for a phylum all of their uh
particular family and identity uh
documentation and so on it's a it's a
very significant pack of uh of paperwork
I'm I totally agree with you that the
productivity needs to get to be much
higher than it is which is why we have
the scheme in place to get to three
decisions per case of work worker per
week by May and then beyond that before
yes it will and back here I mean exactly
the same conversation because there is
no desire as far as I can see on the
evidence I see from the home office to
to put in place a process which is
rigorous demanding and is
um takes into account that the
circumstances from what I understand Mr
icroft what you're saying that the
person comes in provides some documents
and interviews taken place perhaps
there's a phone call that does not take
hours and hours and hours of work to do
it just doesn't does it
I share your ambition to increase the
productivity of this set of caseworkers
we have got a very significant program
of work in place including
um starting off with the pilot and leads
that the home sector has already
mentioned and rolling that out to other
decision-making hubs across the UK so
that uh eventually uh through next year
we do get to those sorts of levels which
will be high enough
um to clear the backlog and to deal with
the incoming flow and we are absolutely
determined to do that I just want to
point out the difference in complexity
of an individual's life uh to pick
another example the Windrush
compensation scheme which we haven't
talked about today but often we do is
also a scheme which requires essentially
very very slow decision making because
that is about the whole life of someone
and so that so the decisions per case
work up a week on that scheme are even
lower than they would be on this island
because the complexity is even greater
because of time unfortunately I'd like
to ask a lot more questions but
um
obviously we're here elected
representatives of the people we're not
here just have an intellectual
discussion
um between ourselves in this room and
many of my constituents many people I
meet around the country if they
understand and they understand that
people are coming here illegally they
want to know why those people cannot be
sent straight back to Albania
immediately
could you please give them an answer
that question
um because they will put in a legal
claim whether it's for Asylum or whether
it's for modern slavery and once they
put in a claim that triggers duties on
the part of the UK state to consider
those claims and they are allowed to
stay in this country while those claims
are being processed and considered so in
terms of if that is the issue then are
we as uh we are we are both members of
the same party are we looking at
legislation to address that problem to
get to make sure and to make sure that
we have the legal power and right to
deport illegal immigrants immediately
well um I I can't go into the detail of
the legislative measures that we're
looking at but we do want to make it
easier to remove people from the UK and
we want to try and avoid this problem
that we are facing right now which is
that people are able to stay here while
their claim is pending that is what is
so important about the Rwanda scheme
because uh once Rwanda uh is
operationalized it will mean that we
will be able to remove people and their
claim for Asylum will be considered
abroad and that will enable a swifter
turnaround the other thing you could say
to your constituents Mr Daley is that
this is not just a UK issue we've been
focusing here about the UK aspects of it
on our system and how to improve that
but other countries are going through
similar things twice as many people
claim Asylum each year in France is in
the UK three or four times as many as
the UK in Germany so we're talking about
a global uh a global challenge here
which requires Global Solutions the um
if we get to this when people are
referred into the modern slavery into
the the mechanism for that it's taking
about 450 days for that to be decided
why can't those claims be decided within
28 days
well there's a legal requirement that
those uh that it takes a minimum period
of time
um and and 28 days is outside of our
legal minimum
legal minimum is now 40 did we move it
yeah 45 I think but we're subjects
why can't we do it within 45 days with
proper management proper people in place
and a proper system to address within 45
days of these claims and get people who
if it's a successful fine within 45 days
and have a process by with people who
fail it can be removed from this country
well uh it used to be it used to take
around that amount of time because the
numbers claiming were far lower than
they are today and frankly the national
referral mechanism which is the process
through which they go has been
overwhelmed and now we have uh uh you
know far far many
right there were there were 2500 nrm
referrals for Albanian Nationals in the
whole of
2021 and and that is a far greater
number than we've seen in years prior to
that that high number of uh cases in our
in our NRI has made it a lot more of a
slower process one question quickly and
then I'm going to bring in Tim
um
another scandal in this country in my
view is rape and serious sexual
offending
um two years ago one in a hundred people
who who made a claim of rape would lead
to a charge we have ridiculously low
charging rates the problem within the
system Home Secretary as far as I'm
concerned we've spoken about this many
times is the lack of referrals from the
police to the crown prosecution service
could I ask what you are doing to
encourage I want you to encourage
telling the police to refer more of
these cases to
um to the CPS so that more women and
girls can get Justice because they're
not getting Justice at this moment in
time well you're absolutely right that
the police are referring a very low
number of complaints to the CPS
um the last figure I saw was around
seven percent but I think it has
actually increased uh in recent months
but that that proportion and volume
needs to increase we have been putting a
lot of effort into trying to fix this
problem operation ceteria is something
which I think is innovative it's about
the closer working between the CPS and
the police because what we're finding is
that the police will uh either I just
stop you there I think the question was
what you were going to do we're very
familiar with this whole area we've
produced a report which I hope you might
have had an opportunity to look at so
we're very familiar with this but I
think the specific question was what you
are going to do so operation ceteria
role out of operation ceteria which I
have a lot of confidence in which is
about the operational relationship
between the police and the CPS better
scrutiny of the decisions that both our
agencies are making and ensuring that
there is more support for victims and a
swifter and a greater uh referral rate
from police to CPS and then uh ideally
an increased charge rate we are working
to support victims ultimately if the
victim drops out of the process before
charge uh or before referral then a
police you know police officer cannot
refer it we need more you know the level
of isvers has been incredibly helpful
for supporting victims through this
process but I agree the end-to-end rape
review sets out what we are doing
there's been an update on progress there
okay thank you thank you very much I'm
sorry to um have to cut you off it's
just that there are some other issues
that we haven't been able to address
this morning and I do want to give Tim
and Simon an opportunity to raise them
so it might be that you have to write
with the responses but um over to you
Tim thank you um chair there are an
awful lot of other things we haven't
been able to cover today so perhaps we
can see you again before Christmas uh
having sex here for round two because I
think there's a lot of questions I want
to ask about
um the very disruptive demonstrations
another issue which has been clogging up
all of our email boxes so another bit of
role play uh I have formed a new group
called just stop just stop oil
and together other members of the
committee we are gluing ourselves to the
highway outside the driveway of the
organizer of just stop oil what will
happen to me
well if you are
um well I I in an Ideal World I have to
just say I'm not in an Ideal World what
will happen to me now I am glued to the
pavement well the police will attend and
the police have been investing huge
amounts of police time effort and
resource into policing protests uh to
the tune of millions tens of millions of
pounds thousands of police hours so they
will attend and they will attend as
swiftly as possible they will then
assess uh what you're doing and look at
you and they will assess whether they
consider that there is a a reasonable
basis for an arrest uh whether that's
obstruction of the highway whether that
is Criminal damage whether that's any
other uh legal offense that they can
identify and if they do so then they
will uh unless that take
listen it really varies depending on the
circumstances when we saw the people
hanging from the gantries that was
taking hours okay because it's very hard
to remove how long should it take I'm
not a Frontline professional I don't
want why is it you understand the the
complete frustration of our constituents
unable to go about their daily uh
business through no fault of their own
and why the public are taking the Law
into their own hands and removing some
of these people with the police standing
by telling them not to and in some cases
arresting members of the the public
under section 137 of the highways Act is
as an offense of a person without lawful
Authority or excuse in any way willfully
obstructs the free passage along a
highway under Section 11 of the public
order at 1986 against protests if a
protest is to intimidate others and
compel them not to do something that
they have the right to do or not do
something that they have the right not
to so do those are two very clear
existing parts of the law that should
make it very easy for an attending
police officer very swiftly to remove
people who are obstructing the highway
and intimidating people trying to go
about their law business why are the
police taking ages to intervene and
people's lives are being disrupted
by the College of so I've taken a real
it's the problem that you're
highlighting and I do have some concerns
I think on the whole the police have
been very robust and done uh you know
acted very admirably in the
circumstances
well well they have when it comes to
just top oil since April of 2022 they've
arrested 1700 people they've arrested
the on the M25 protests uh between in
the beginning of November they arrested
64 people between the first on the month
of October the Met police alone arrested
677 people there were many examples how
long it takes before that their
disruption is removed and how many of
them are actually in Jail receiving a
meaningful and proportionate penalty for
the very substantial disruption that
they've been committing are you happy
with the College of policing's five-step
appeal guidance which is a simple appeal
to ask the person to comply a reasoned
appeal a personal appeal the fourth day
age is a final appeal and then
eventually action it's a nonsense isn't
it we know what they are doing and they
are getting the pub extended publicity
from doing it and then they're getting
little more than a slap on the wrist and
as we've seen in the van Gogh protesters
one of them even only a suspended
sentence is making a mockery of the
government's claim to be the party and
the government of Law and Order isn't it
whilst this is going on well I have
looked at the College of policing
guidance on protests and I have some
questions about it and I am going to be
speaking to the College of policing I
want to look and ensure that the police
are following robust guidance and that
is a Live question for me in the home
office okay I would also say you know
there was a recent case of Ziegler and
we saw some of the cases relating to
protests like the Colston statute case
which I referred as attorney general to
the court of appeal on this very issue
you know framework there are human
rights considerations and that is uh the
legal framework within which we are
working if you could write to us with
anything else you you want to tell us
Simon I know we've got very little time
left do you want to just raise the issue
and then we'll get it in writing from
the Home Secretary if I may thank you
and I beg your Indulgence for just a
couple of minutes
um so no role play with me just want to
talk about fraud
um so it's the number one crime in the
UK 41 I think of all crimes are fraud or
fraud related
um I spent a decade working in fraud and
financial crime with government with law
enforcement with industry trying to get
them to work better together before I
came here and much to my frustration
when a constituent comes to me and says
they've been defrauded after 20 000
pounds I still don't know what to do to
help them
um the PM said that there was a fraud
plan forthcoming my question to you is
when can we expect it and can we expect
it to meet the scale of the challenge
that our constituents are facing at the
moment
well you are right that uh we will be
publishing a new Ford strategy to
address exactly the issue that you've
raised and I I do think that this is
um a big priority for us because of the
um the relevance that it plays in Modern
Day crime fighting
um and we need um you know to think
about all options I think prevention
actually is far better than cure I I'm
very keen to explore ways in which the
telecoms companies the software
companies the banks law enforcement can
all work better together and use
technology to prevent hackers getting to
your constituent uh whereby she is
handing over her life savings online we
shouldn't be getting when we get to that
point we're actually too late
um so I think there's a massive
prevention element that I want to lead
and instigate and that will be set out
in the fortunate secondly I also think
our policing can we can we have this in
writing because we really are running
very shorts in time and I just wanted to
raise with you if you would write to me
as well about I would like to know about
Linton onu and why the decision to
cancel that happened at a time when you
were very short of accommodation to move
people out of manston so could I have an
explanation for that could you also set
out I think you'd already agree to do
this the information around the
exceptional circumstances around
detaining people Beyond 24 hours how
many people were detained up to the
five-day limit and then how many
additional people were detained Beyond
five days that would be very helpful to
have that and could I also ask if we
could see the advice that was given to
members of staff at manston so border
Force immigration officers and
contractors about the legal basis of
manston and what powers members of Staff
border Force immigration officers had
and could use
I think that would be very helpful as
well if I could ask for that information
to be sent to the committee
can I thank all three clarify you asked
me about the um judicial reviews issued
around Mount and I've got a
clarification for you so there are no
actual judicial reviews which have been
issued I.E in claim forms but there are
pre-action protocol letters which we
have received and there are five
preemption protocol letters that we have
received okay thank you for that
um can I thank all three of you for
attending today the concentration has
obviously been on immigration and
manston and Small Boat Crossings but as
Tim Lawton said there are many other
issues that we remain very concerned
about and will be wanting to ask
questions of we're grateful for you
attending today Home Secretary we hope
we can get a date in the diary if not
before Christmas very early in 2023 to
carry on asking you questions and
scrutinizing the work of this very
important department so thank you for
your time today with pleasure
thank you thank you
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended